normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government this
is the big story it actually is pretty
interesting Donald Trump greeted by
cheers upon arrival at UFC 295 in New
York City it wasn't just Donald Trump it
was Tucker Carlson and Kid Rock and I
must stress this for you all again in
New York City probably what is this the
deepest blue blue can be in this country
I well no that's not fair I mean I guess
Portland maybe well and they did flip a
City Council seat last week a City
Council seat in the Bronx wait a
republican
yeah and there was a there was another
flip I think in Long Island wow this is
getting CRA New Yorkers are getting
pissed they're tired of all this garbage
I think seeing Donald Trump get massive
cheers in New York City should be as
soon as I see this I'm like all the
polls that are claiming Trump's within a
point or two above Joe Biden they're
wrong he's got to be higher than that
you you you look I know we can all say
that UFC fighters are base and so the
fans are probably more you know right
leaning whatever I don't believe that
the people I know who are watching
fights they're just regular people UFC
is a mainstream popular sport and Donald
Trump shows up in New York City to Mad
Square Garden and the and the Crowd Goes
Nuts I think it's fair to say Joe Biden
can't win but I also think everyone
listening to this show already knows
it's not going to be Joe Biden anyway
right well and these are probably a lot
of people from New Jersey also you know
there's like New Jersey and New York in
the crowd yeah but it's all blue it's
all it's awesome yeah I think it's great
did you see Bill Burr's wife was
flipping oh that was great too yeah she
flipped off Trump she flipped off Trump
from see see it's it's New York it's not
all uh all love for Trump I guess people
Express so so so so what's our what's
our prescription here or what's our
what's our prediction is probably the
better way to put it it's it's Donald
Trump in New York City getting Thundurus
Applause with Tucker Tucker Carlson okay
just right there I mean Tucker Cron's
walking through medicine Square guard
and everyone's screaming and cheering
okay it's not a good sign for for Joe
Biden in 2024 and the rest of the
Democrats I think in uh what was it in
Kentucky the last election last week the
only thing Democrats won was the the
governor's race and it was super close
and it was an incumbent so I mean right
come advantage and then the rest of the
all these other positions ended up going
to Republicans so it is looking like at
least right now based on what we saw
last week and what I mean a lot of
people are saying it was really bad for
Republicans but I think what we're
seeing right now in New York City you
mentioned them flipping a seat I don't I
don't see how Democrats can win unless
they radically shift their strategy
right now what about all of the wins
that we saw last week like in Ohio they
had a sweeping abortion law that was
like a constitutional amendment and then
um a number of other places those are
wins for Democrats yeah we saw a lot of
democrat wins last week they legalized
weed in Ohio they legalized weed in Ohio
yeah I don't I think that's that's a
mistake Republicans are making I who who
was who was talking about this I don't
know maybe Mike cernovich was tweeting
about it abortion is generally popular
in the United States to the point where
people don't actually care the full
extent of what's being legalized the
pro-life position is not going to win
out yeah it's something that if you want
to actually make a pro-life change
you've got to somehow get the population
to follow you for other reasons and then
kind of subconsciously get them to to
become pro-life but screaming it is not
going to make people this is why I think
it's important to like if you're
pro-life it makes more sense to Advocate
against abortion than to advocate for
abortion to be illegal yeah like they're
not the same thing abortion can be legal
and you can encourage people not to do
it right making showing the morality of
it I think watching the baby get
dismembered in the womb as it's been
pulled out or just offering more options
for moms like you can be a mom it's okay
you know yeah I was talking to a friend
of mine and he was mentioning how he he
he he bought something he he well I
don't want to give out too many details
cuz some you know it's other dude's
private life but he was trying to help a
local kid with some extracurricular
activities and his family was not very
well off so he said let me help you out
and you know buy you some some stuff to
help your kids and when he said this a
bunch of people started calling him a
creepo and a pedo for trying to for
helping this little girl with like her
school stuff and he was like man I felt
so bad I was like what did I do
something wrong like why are people
yelling at me like posted online like
hey I just you know was buying this
stuff for this family and they tacked
him for it and I'm like it is really
funny that what there there's a cultural
narrative for guys like we have all
these stories where a guy sting on an
airplane and then it's like he'll be
sitting next to a kid and the flight t
comes up and says you have to move
because you're a man sitting next to a
child and then we've had these for years
and then for women you have these
stories where it's like oh don't have a
family it's bad for the environment or
you're not going to have fun or you're
going to Reddit it's like man they
really don't want people having kids no
they don't and they don't want people
around kids they just want to get rid of
kids entirely yeah right yeah I guess
but at any rate I don't know where are
we at I got a prediction on this Gavin
Newsome comes in with on a chariot of
fire and everyone's like why is this guy
but then the media pushes him so hard
for a year and they're like Trump bad
new some good and you get a bunch of
people behind it and then unless we have
election integrity and the votes are on
machines behind the scenes I have no way
to verify whether or not the votes are
going to get hacked and flip 5149 but I
don't trust the process if it's done
secretly on proprietary machines these
days I just don't I I got to be honest I
don't know where we're at in terms of
like I I have a general idea Joe Biden
can't win as of right now but there's
got to be some kind of insane and
dramatic change that happens over the
next several months in order for there
to be a viable race for Democrats in
2024 but look at Joe Biden's entire
career he's a Serial liar in the 80s
when he was running for president he was
caught plagiarizing the speech of a
British politician his whole life story
he's demented he thought he was fighting
a parthe in South Africa he thought he
was fighting for civil rights in the US
so he's out of touch and I think
accordingly he's going to be out of
touch enough to believe he has a chance
and I think he'll stay in the race yeah
but they got to remove him right I mean
what so so there's a couple views one is
that the Deep state or what you want to
call it is like why won't Joe Biden stop
we need someone else we can't win and so
now you're seeing all the hunter Biden
stuff Bubble Up and the threat of
impeachment and conviction if Joe Biden
doesn't leave people think they're going
to take they're going to remove him by
force from office in a speech I think
was it today he said president Harris
well he said that like eight times I
know but he says it a bunch I think that
I think he's really just trying to get
us used to it and they'd have to remove
her too cuz obviously they can't run her
as well because she's so unpopular
probably less popular than he is so yeah
no uh the impeachment could actually
have some legs if uh people inside his
own party get behind it because but the
problem is the impeachment has to do
with Ukraine and they're they're
sensitive about that because they're so
embedded in Ukraine and they don't want
to admit defeat there and the Ukraine
impeachment gets to Joe Biden's
corruption there and his big role in
causing this whole mess well this is why
I'm saying I don't know where we're at
cuz that's a really great point if they
move to if Joe Biden won't leave and
they know he's gonna lose okay hold on
slow down if Donald Trump wins all their
War plans are going to get screwed up
it's it's not like you know Trump's
going to just end everything overnight
but it's certainly he's certainly not
going to give them what they want so
they can't have Donald Trump but he's
the front runner for the Republicans and
he's going to do really well so then
they have Joe Biden okay well if Joe
Biden stays in the race he's going to
lose and they're going to get Trump
can't have that but if they try to
remove Joe Biden using impeachment
you're right it's Ukraine and now
whoopsy Daisy how many people are are
going to get caught up in whatever that
disaster is they do have them though on
the classified documents case there is
an investigation into that we which we
forgot about because it gets buried but
they could pull that out if they really
wanted something to get him on they
could use that and if they do then they
come back and say oh look we're being
fair Trump you can't be president either
I think if they go after every time I
see them um talking about the Biden
classified documents I think this is
just a way to get Trump because they
don't care what happens to Biden and
they want Trump out of the way well if
you're someone inside the establishment
and you hate both Biden and Trump uh for
your own reasons then this classified
documents thing it's like you kill two
birds with one stone because you pretend
like you're applying the law equally yep
you claim you're upholding Justice and
you get them both so if I'm making a
prediction I think they're going to go
with that if they really want is it
going to be Nome versus Dan
santis aren't they debating soon aren't
they having that happen that's the plan
yeah the thing is I don't think you can
stop Trump he's just shown to be so
resilient he freestyled his entire 2016
campaign right
inable yeah he's you know he has inevit
if you look at him physically he has a
terrible diet but he's just seems
indestructible he's 77 years old so the
only person who can really stop TR he
always out there playing golf anyway
there you go yeah you say the only
person who can stop Trump only person
stop Trump is Trump himself somehow he
he hangs it up personally but otherwise
I just don't think all these cases
against him like what is he facing 700
years yeah but you look at them and you
go I mean maybe on the classified
documents one there's something I don't
know I I don't know that one too closely
but the other ones like the racket ering
case in Georgia it seems everyone who's
not a hardcore partisan Democrat
understands what's going on there I
think with the Dos I don't think that
they get them on the documents because
you have judge canon in Florida who has
now pushed the court date back and she
said you know we're not going to do this
on an accelerated schedule so that's
just going to drag on for a while I
think he I think they have a better shot
of getting him on the January sixth case
because they've got a gag order slapped
on them already right um and they're
really going to go hard after him on
that one they have a judge who has
already with other January 6 cases uh
advocated for or and issued sentences
that are longer even than the justice
department had asked for I think that's
where they're I think they're going to
get him in that one and I think they I
think theyve a shot at getting in
Georgia I don't how would you describe
yourself politically if you would Aaron
traditionally leftwing so and the and
the meaning of that has changed in
recent years because now to be leftwing
you have to side with neocons to support
proxy wars like in Ukraine but which is
weird yes
full circle they say yeah exactly so I'd
say traditionally leftwing so that's why
I think it's interesting because uh you
know based on your political views where
you are are are are people calling you
right-wing have they been calling you
right-wing for some time yeah ever since
I started opposing Russia gate which I
thought was the dumbest thing of all
time uh and it speaks to this issue
we're talking about this desperate
effort to get Trump and also undermine
any diplomacy between the US and Russia
by calling him a Russian asset and all
the conspiracy theories that came with
that ever since I started questioning
that was called rightwing I was called
an apologist for Trump even though as a
side even like putting a even if I
didn't care about facts and being a
journalist which is what when you're a
journalist you're supposed to follow the
facts no matter where they lead uh for
for partisan purposes putting that aside
from a political point of view I was
also against it because I thought it was
a big gift to Trump because what's a
bigger gift to Trump than trying to
oppose him from the soulle point of view
and this really was the obsession of him
being a Russian asset like putting all
your eggs into the basket of a crazy
conspiracy
I thought it was a big gift to him and
the Republicans and so because I was
opposed to that I was accused of uh of
supporting Trump and then you were
critical of uh war in Ukraine and then I
was of course I was because one of the
reasons why I hated Russia gate was
because it also promoted this neocon
narrative that we should not have
diplomacy with Russia that Russia is
responsible for all of our problems and
it's a good thing to fight the war in
Ukraine rather than resolve it with the
Peace Accords that were on the table
that's what Trump's first impeachment
was about people forget this he was
Peach for briefly pausing some weapons
to Ukraine while allegedly pressuring
Ukraine to investigate the bidens and by
the way the case was the case if you
looked at it never had any actual
evidence Trump did make some dumb
comments in a phone call to zalinsky but
the fundamental charge against Trump
that he was like leveraging us weapons
to Blackmail zinsky there was actually
never there was never actually any
evidence for it what it did do was
promote this cold war narrative that we
should be fighting this war with Russia
Adam Schiff on the house floor when he
was leading the impeachment said that we
Aid Ukraine so that we can fight Russia
over there we don't have to fight Russia
here and I remember thinking is this
what being a left Wier is now we have to
support uh fighting a proxy war with
Russia and look where it got us it got
us into this allout hot War over the
last few years so one of reasons why I
thought Russia gate was a huge scam and
a big danger and it's it's weird how all
of these like I don't know how to
describe it these weird authoritarian
things align with what is described as
the left today and if you are somebody
who holds left economic views but
criticizes the war machine or like Adam
schiff's statements and and how they've
gone after Trump you are now right-wing
you are far right they'll call you far
right for simply being like well Trump
didn't do that oh we got you yeah
they'll call you a Russian asset and
they will look the other way or cheer on
people being censored in the name of
cracking down on so-called
disinformation so look at for example
the reporting on the hunter Biden laptop
before the election they rolled out the
Russia gate Playbook because some
embarrassing emails from Hunter bid's
laptop emerged and rather than let
people look at the contents of the
laptop and make up their own minds they
censored it in the name of fighting
Russia which was of course another
complete scam so that entrenched that
Playbook but I don't think it's
exclusive to the left now in the because
of this conflict in Gaza you're seeing
plenty of Republican politicians calling
for censoring voices that support
Palestinian rights you're seeing people
called anti-semites unfairly you're
seeing College groups being shut down
like at Columbia two two groups just got
shut down for their Palestinian advocacy
so I do think on both sides you have
this um certainly during the Russia gate
era it was it it was happening a lot on
the liberal side and people like me were
the target of it this is a crazy thing
the uh the the the Israel Palestine
issue has ripped both the left and the
right in half in this really weird way
it's pretty wild and I I think it's I I
I I don't necessarily know how this
position starts but there are these
funny Comics uh ston toss is a comic
where it's like a communist with like a
guilded age oligarch and they're both
pulling the rope together and there's a
Libertarian and a fascist pulling the
rope together like what is what is this
like what is this political debate that
we're having and so what you end up with
is uh somehow several years ago people
who were right leaning or conservative
in their values were moving towards pro-
Free Speech people who were disaffected
liberals or po former Democrats are now
agreeing with Trump supporters Trump was
moderate even Steve Bannon says he's a
moderate in our movement no no no
vox.com called Trump a moderate back in
2015 and and so these like you look at
Trump's bum stock ban he is not this
farri you know Anarchist or libertarian
or anything like these things so what's
interesting is that as long as Israel
wasn't in the debate so protective Edge
happens 2014 and then after that you get
this period where there are people who
are very critical of is is and people
are very supportive is of Israel but as
long as they're not talking about it
they're all working together and the
same is true for pro Gaza or or critical
of of Hamas thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net